-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for tuning in.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's going to be fun tonight.
Well, let's get
to some news, guys.
A week after renaming
their company Meta,
Facebook has learned
that there's already another
tech company called Meta
and they won't sell their name
for less than $20 million.
[ Laughter ]
When asked why they didn't do
their research, Facebook said,
"We did.
We just did it on Facebook."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the name Meta
is already being used.
Facebook was like "Fine,
if that's taken,
we're just going to go
with our backup choice --
TikTok."
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Speaking of social media,
this week,
Jay-Z joined Instagram...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...racked up more
than a million followers,
then deleted his account
a day later.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He was like,
"I don't want to get hooked.
It'll be like Etsy
all over again."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, after 24 hours,
Jay-Z said, "Sunsets, food,
people's kids, I'm good.
I don't need to do this."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, all it took was a day
for Jay-Z to realize,
"I'm a billionaire married
to Beyoncé.
Who cares what anyone
else is doing?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some news from Washington --
the White House announced
that their deadline
for their workplace
vaccine mandate is January 4th.
It's great timing --
make sure everyone is vaccinated
right after the holidays.
[ Laughter ]
Some more COVID news --
I heard that there's
a potentially faster-spreading
Delta variant moving
through the U.S.,
called Delta-Plus.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
It's basically the Delta
variant, but, if you get it,
you can also stream movies
and shows for $13 a month.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Got to admit it's a good deal.
-Extra leg room.
[ Laughter ]
Some big sports news --
Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers
has tested positive for COVID
and it turns out
he may have lied
about being vaccinated.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yep, he told reporters
he was immunized,
which some people
are saying is misleading,
but that's not the only
confusing statement
that he's made
about his vaccine status.
For example, in one
press conference, he said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Yeah. In another press
conference, he said...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, he cleared
things up by saying...
[ Cheering and applause ]
Some business news --
I read that CVS wants
to start hiring doctors
so that they can become a major
healthcare service provider.
Yeah, instead of an X-ray,
they'll just drag you
across the scanner
at the self-checkout machine.
[ Laughter ]
Boop!
Sorry, it didn't go through.
Get over here!
[ Laughter ]
-Beep!
-That's right,
CVS wants to hire doctors.
It's kind of interesting,
but, even more interesting
are the questions
on the application
to become a CVS doctor.
I'll show you what I mean.
First up, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then there's...
Next up, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, there's...
Oh, that's --
-Whoa!
I never thought about that.
-Yeah.
Thank you.
Some more business news --
this weekend,
UPS is looking to hire more
than 60,000 employees
at its annual
Brown Friday event.
-[ Snickers ]
[ Laughter ]
-And, of course --
[ Laughter and applause ]
And of course,
they won't hire anyone
because nobody will attend
an event called Brown Friday.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how the UPS event works.
It starts on Friday, but,
if you show up three days late,
the job is yours.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, today, Starbucks
debuted their festive new drink,
called the Iced Sugar Cookie
Almond Milk Latte.
[ Audience oohs ]
But they're not the only ones
getting into the holiday spirit.
Check out this new ad I just saw
from Dunkin' Donuts.
-[ Boston accent ]
We here at Dunkin'
are serving up
some wicked awesome
new holiday drinks.
So come on down and get
something for your kid brother.
Like our new...
[ Laughter ]
Or how about a piping hot...
[ Audience ohs ]
Or maybe try our new...
It's just a Styrofoam cup
filled with Sam Adams,
[ Laughter ]
so you can drink it
on the tee.
From Dunkin'.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Hey, get this -- I saw that
a goat cheese from Spain
just beat out
over 4,000 other entries
to win first place
at the World Cheese Awards.
Sounds delicious,
but I wish they'd come up
with a better name than...
[ Laughter and ews ]
-Goat Whiz.
[ Laughter ]
That's not the real name.
You're making that up.
-What's that?
-You're making that up.
-No, no, I'm serious.
-Really, it was Goat Whiz?!
-Yeah, I'm really serious.
-Fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally,
a couple in New Zealand
unearthed a 17-pound potato
that they think is
the largest ever.
Here's a photo of it.
This is real.
-Wow!
[ Audience oohs ]
-Look at the size of that.
If you try
to make mashed potatoes
out of that thing,
it actually fights back.
[ Laughter ]
Can we take a look at it again?
It looks like something
you'd see on Brown Friday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, we have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody.
Come on, Higgins.
-♪ Unh, call it Captain Rock ♪
♪ I started at the bottom,
now, I'm lonely at the top ♪
♪ But I ain't hardly
finished climbing ♪
♪ No, I'm only at the top ♪
♪ Before I figured
I should probably show 'em ♪
♪ Show 'em what I got ♪
♪ Aye yo, something dirty
skirted off the lot ♪
♪ It's blacker than the kettle
and I'm darker than the pot ♪
♪ Aight ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What a show we have
for you tonight.
She is one of the biggest stars
on the planet
and you can see her as a coach
on "The Voice,"
Mondays and Tuesdays here
on NBC.
Ariana Grande is joining us!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yes!
The best!
Ariana Grande.
Plus, from the new movie
"The French Dispatch,"
Adrien Brody is here!
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And we got great music
from Blxst
featuring Ty Dolla Sign!
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Blxst.
And then, later in the show,
an all-new
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
But, right now, guys,
it is time for
"Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-First up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, there's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
"How long they --"
After that, we have...
That sounds like a...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Groaning ]
[ Coughs ]
-"Agh!"
Next, there is...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
What?
-Yeah!
-Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
-Wow.
-I thought you were at Hardee's.
[ Laughter ]
-Next up, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa! Oops.
All Berrys.
-Yeah.
-Accidental.
-Accidental. They didn't know
it was happening.
-No.
-Yeah.
All Berrys are here, yeah.
After that, we've got...
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh...
Iced Sugar Cookie
Almond Milk Latte!"
Enough! Enough!
[ Laughter ]
What?!
-Oh, my God!
-What?!
-Too Many Berries!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Aw, there you go.
-Whoo!
-Next, there's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just Beyond.
Finally, we have...
[ Laughter ]
There you have it, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's "Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."